The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
JOHN W. ROBERTS: We'll
be talking about--
I heard last time I
had bad handwriting.
And I guess this isn't
much improved yet,
but I will try to be more
deliberate if not more skilled.
Stochastic-- all right.
So as you may
remember last time,
we were talking about
different assumptions
that we've used in all
the techniques we've
applied so far.
Now, we assume that we
have a model of the system,
that the system
is deterministic--
that's not really any
better handwriting,
but this is the one
that last time we
talked about getting
rid of anyway, right?
Stochastic system,
stochastic dynamics.
So that's what we
tried to remove.
And then the state is known.
So sort of already
gotten rid of this one
in some of our discussions.
And today we're going
to talk about what
you do if you don't a model.
And this is something
that's actually
very important in a lot
of interesting systems.
And the systems that we work
on the lab, some of them
we try to model, but some
of them help us to model.
So this, dealing without
this, is a very useful thing
to be able to do.
So hopefully, you'll
all at the end
appreciate the tremendous power
of model-free reinforcement
learning.
So the basic idea is,
again, we have this policy
parameterization alpha, which
somehow defines our policy.
And the problem sets that you
recently did, it's open loop,
so you just have one
alpha for every time step.
You also can imagine these are
gains on a feedback policy,
entries of the K matrix,
or PD gains, any way you
want to parameterize it.
And you think about you use--
these parameters-- now, this is
the most simple interpretation.
There's a lot more complicated
ways of looking at it,
but I'm going to look at
the most simple way first.
You send this into your system.
So you can run your system
with these parameters.
Now, this is,
again, sort of like
what you did in the problem set.
You have a fixed initial
condition, fixed cost function,
you give it a policy, you run
it, and you see how it does.
And so what you
get, you get J. You
get the cost of
running that policy.
So the question is
that, previously we've
talked about, OK, if you
have a model of the system,
there's a lot of
things you can do.
You can do back prop to
get the specific gradient;
do something like SNOPT, you can
do gradient descent using that.
You can do, depending
on the dimensionality,
you can do value iteration.
So there's a lot of options
when you have a model.
But if you don't, if you don't
know how the system works,
if it's really just a black
box where I have a policy
parameterization, I get a cost,
how do we achieve anything
in that context?
We don't have any
sort of information
about how these things
relate to each other.
Well, the thing is we do have
some information in that we
can execute this black box.
We can test it, right?
We can run our policy
and see how well it does.
So what would you say
is the crudest thing
you could do if you had a
system like this, a black box?
You give it an open loop
tape, let's say, you run it,
and it tells you the cost.
What could we do?
AUDIENCE: SNOPT could also--
well, not that we'll
[INAUDIBLE] SNOPT.
But SNOPT could also--
or you have methods for
estimating the gradient.
JOHN W. ROBERTS: You can do
finite differences, right?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, do finite--
JOHN W. ROBERTS: So finite
differences, exactly.
So what you can
do is you can say,
let's talk about, again,
this is a notation. [? So ?]
what we're using is simple.
A lot of times they parameterize
it in a different way.
But yeah.
So you have pretty
much in this context--
let's say we have a
deterministic cost.
So we don't have
a random system.
We'll talk about
random systems later.
Let's say we have a
deterministic cost, which
is a function of our alpha.
So what are our parameters,
our parameter vector?
So what we do is we
say, OK, let's say
I have a 2D system
alpha 1, alpha 2.
Now, we don't know what
this function is right now.
But let's just say it's a simple
function like this, convex,
where these are the contour
lines, and what we want
is we want to get to the middle.
So this is sort of the local
min, and we start here.
Now, what-- how SNOPT
could get these gradients,
and sort of the simplest
thing you can imagine doing,
would be, all right, well--
one of the simplest things
you can imagine doing
is actually another
very simple thing.
You measure here.
So you run the system.
You get J at this point.
So you run the system,
you get J at this point.
You run the system, you
get J at this point.
But you take these differences,
divide by your displacement,
and what you get is you get some
estimate of the local gradient.
And if those distances are
small enough and your evaluation
sort of nice enough, you
can get arbitrarily close
to the true gradient there.
And this will tell you, OK, you
want to move in this direction,
right?
Now, the problem with this is
that you have to do n plus 1,
where n is the number of
dimensions, evaluations,
to get this.
So you sort of have
to evaluate at alpha
and at alpha plus delta
0, 0, 0, dot, dot, dot,
alpha plus 0 delta 0, 0,
dot, dot, dot, et cetera.
Now, obviously,
these things just
have to be linearly
independent, actually.
But you might as
well do it this way.
Do these finite
differences, you get
an estimate of the gradient.
You can hand it
to SNOPT and SNOPT
can try to do fancier things.
Or you can do gradient descent,
where you get this gradient,
you compute it, and then you
do an update where I say, OK,
now my alpha at n plus 1 equals
alpha at n plus some delta
alpha.
And you can say, OK, delta
alpha equals negative eta
and then dJ d alpha.
That's a vector.
And so this is
our learning rate.
That says, OK, we have
the gradient here.
How far are we going to move?
Setting that can be an issue.
But you update your
alpha like this.
And you can just keep doing
that over and over again,
keep evaluating it
over and over again.
And eventually, you
should move in to the 0.
You should get to a local min.
The thing is that doing n
plus 1 evaluations every time
is expensive.
Now, you could say you
could cut that down a bit
if you were to reuse
some evaluations
and stuff like that.
But the point is that you have
to do a lot of evaluations
to get this local information.
And if you move very
far, you sort of
have to discard those and do
all those evaluations again.
So short of doing
a lot of evaluation
to get sort of an accurate
estimate of the gradient right
here.
Then you're throwing a lot
of it away when you move,
and the gradient could change.
And so in that sense, doing
all these evaluations maybe
is wasteful, because
you're getting more--
you're sort of being more
careful than you have to.
And then you're just going
to lose that information
once you move somewhere else
and have to evaluate it again.
So there's another thing.
This one, you could
say, is even more crude.
This is, at least in
evolutionary algorithm
[? screen, ?] I think they
call it just hill climbing.
I mean, all these things are
sort of hill climbing or valley
descending.
But what you can
also imagine doing
is just having a point here,
and now we just randomly
perturb that.
So I don't do this.
This is deterministic, right?
I could randomly perturb
and just be like, OK, well,
what if I'm here?
That's worse, right?
The cost is higher.
So you just throw it
out, don't use it.
Do it again here, that's better.
So now we just keep this.
And we just do this over and
over, discarding bad ones,
keeping good ones,
until we get back there.
But the thing is,
is that there you're
doing all these evaluations.
When they get worse, you're
just throwing them out,
and you're acting like they
give you no information.
But there is
information in that.
Even if it gets worse, and
by how much it gets worse,
how much it gets better, there's
information in all of that.
And you're getting information
when you do the evaluation.
So I throw it away and just sort
of like cast out these things
that do worse.
So that's sort of the idea
of the stochastic gradient
descent, is that we're
going to follow this sort
of like random kind of idea.
Well, instead of doing this
deterministic evaluation
of the local gradient, we're
going to randomize the system,
and we're going to get
an estimate the gradient
stochastically, and then
we're going to follow that.
And we're going to get
as much information out
of that as possible.
That's one of the
important thing,
is generally these systems,
this evaluation is all the cost.
Pretty much everything
is dominated
by checking your cost of
the [INAUDIBLE] policy.
So you want to get as much
as you can out of each one.
And stochastic
gradient descent is
sort of a powerful way of doing
that when you have no model.
That's definitely more
efficient than hill climbing.
So now the question is, what
is the appropriate process
for doing this?
How do we randomly
sample these guys
and actually improve our policy?
So I'm going to
write down an update.
This is a common update.
It's the weight
perturbation update.
It also shows up in an
identical form in reinforce,
if you see any of those.
We'll talk about all those.
But when you can look at the
[? performance ?] update--
is my handwriting
at all legible?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
JOHN W. ROBERTS: Yeah?
OK.
So you want to look at this
[? performance ?] update.
Take my word for now
that this makes sense.
Well, changing the alpha bits.
OK.
So I'm saying,
change your alpha.
Here we have the
same learning rate.
So this is like in the
deterministic gradient descent.
And then here's
where you evaluate.
And this z is noise.
So when you perturb
your policy, this
is sort of the vector of how
you perturb that alpha vector.
So this is sort of--
this is a z, this
is a z, this is a z.
Those z's are these
perturbations to this.
So what you can do is
we can say-- a simple
and a very common way is to
have the vector z is distributed
as a multivariate Gaussian,
so where each element of z
is iid with the same
standard deviation, mean 0.
And so you sort of
draw this z from your--
you draw a sort of
sample z, you evaluate
how well it does, you
evaluate how well you
do with your sort
of nominal policy
right now, calculate
this difference,
and then you move in
the direction of z.
So I'll try to draw this in 1D
and then 2D so it makes sense.
So here in 1D, you can
say this is our 1 alpha.
If this is J, so here's
our cost function.
So we'll be here.
Now, our z in this
case is just a scalar.
But so our z is
going to be mean 0.
And it's going to have
a Gaussian distribution.
But when you sample from
this, you evaluate--
I should actually probably
keep that update up
at the same time.
So you sample, you
get this change.
So this is sort of my J alpha.
This right here is
my J alpha plus z.
And imagine this change.
That's going to say,
OK, the cost went up.
It went up by some amount.
That's the difference.
I'm going to move in
the direction of z.
So z is just a scalar.
Here it's just going
to be sort of the sign
and the magnitude of it.
And then I'm going to move
sort of opposite this.
So I perturb z. z went
in this direction.
It got bigger.
That change, then,
is a positive number.
So we're going to move down by
amount sort of eta that change,
right?
And so if it gets a lot
worse, we move down farther.
If it gets a bit worse,
we move down a bit.
Does that makes sense?
And so when you're
measuring here,
you're going to get small
change for the same z.
When you, again, you draw
your Gaussian around that,
if you get a small
change, you're
just going to move a bit.
When I'm here, where
it's really steep,
I'll get the same perturbation,
I'm going to get bigger change.
I'm going to move even farther.
And I'll update here.
And so if I do this
a bunch of times,
you can imagine I
descend into local min.
Does that make sense?
And this is every time you're
drawing the stochastically.
So you're not doing this
[INAUDIBLE] term thing.
Every time you do it,
you could be updating,
you could try worse,
you could try better.
But stochastically, you
can sort of intuitively
see why it's going
to sort of descend.
Does that make sense?
AUDIENCE: This is heavily
depending on the fact
that the function is sort
of [INAUDIBLE] direction?
JOHN W. ROBERTS:
It's sort of what?
AUDIENCE: It's like the
function that you're looking at,
if you're looking--
if you increase,
like in this case,
like alpha in one
direction versus other one,
the changes are sort of
similar in both ways.
JOHN W. ROBERTS: No.
I mean, that can affect the
performance of the algorithm.
But yeah, I can draw that.
These are sort of common
pathological cases.
Let's look at in 2D.
So this is what
you're saying, right?
Now, the ideal one would be--
again, we can draw
a contour map again.
Now, you'd be-- this is
about the same, right?
You're saying this is about
sort of isotropic or whatever.
You're here, you perturb
yourself randomly
so your Gaussian is going
to put you anywhere here.
And you measure somewhere.
You get better, so you're going
to move in that direction,
depending on what eta is,
and I'll get an update.
You're saying, well, what
happens if we're actually
in trouble, and
we have something
that looks like this, right?
Saying that's a problem?
Well, that can hurt
the convergence of it.
It can be slower.
But it still works.
Because you can see--
like, let's say I'm here.
Now, it's really steep here,
and it's really shallow here.
So what's going to happen
is when I perturb it,
I'm still going to--
my perturbation
in this direction
is going have an effect--
maybe it's relatively shallow--
but then in this direction it's
going to be very sensitive.
And so when I move it more
in this direction and I
move very far, and I'm going
to go down here first--
I'm going to descend
the steep part--
and then slowly converge
in on the shallow part.
That's sort of called the,
I think, the banana problem,
where you sort of have
this massive bowl,
and you go really quick right
down here, and then really
slowly.
And so the thing is that
if it's all very shallow,
that's not a problem.
You can make your
learning rate bigger,
you can make your
sample further out,
and then it sort of just
doesn't matter, right?
But this asymmetry in
these things is an issue.
Now, there are some
ways of dealing
with that if you have an
idea of how asymmetric it is.
We can talk about this later.
But it'll still descend.
And actually, you
can show, and I'm
about to show, that
this update actually
follows an expectation
it moves in the direction
of the true gradient.
So, I mean, randomly it
can bounce all around.
But in expectation, it will
move in the right direction.
And if you're having
deterministic evaluations--
well, we're going to do a
linear analysis at first.
But you actually can
show that it'll always
move within 90 degrees
of the true gradient
if you have
deterministic valuations.
So you'll never
actually get worse.
You can move parallel
and not improve,
but you'll never move
sort of the wrong sign
of [? those two ?] parameters.
All right.
So then yeah.
Let's look at why that
is in some detail then.
So again, our delta
alpha, same up there.
So I just won't waste
time rewriting it.
And let's do-- let's look at
it in a first-order Taylor
expansion of our cost function.
So look at it locally
where you look at sort
of like the linear term.
So our J-- and we
linearize around alpha.
So our J of alpha
plus z, well, that
is approximately equal to--
for small z-- alpha plus
dJ d alpha transpose z.
So that's the first-order
Taylor expansion.
Now, if we examine
this then, we plug this
in for J alpha plus
z in that update,
we're going to cancel out of
this term, our J alpha term,
and we're going to get that
delta alpha approximately
negative eta dJ d alpha z z.
So now, what does
this look like?
This is sort of
like a dot product
between the gradient
with respect
to alpha and our noise vector.
All right?
So and this is going to be
about equal to negative eta.
This thing we can then write
[INAUDIBLE] i is 1 to N
of dJ d alpha i
zi times vector z.
All right.
So here then, if we
multiply that out,
so we're going to get this
vector and eta, because you're
multiplying that coefficient
times each term individually.
You're going to get the vector.
And then the same thing.
This one's going to be
some dJ d alpha zi zN.
Now, if we take
expectation of this,
we get another distribution.
We know that each zi is iid.
Do you know iid?
That they're all--
they're all distributed
the exact same distribution,
all the sort of mean 0,
Gaussian, standard
deviation sigma.
And they're all independent.
So if we do that, we can then
take the expectation of delta
alpha.
We can pull that eta out front,
because expectation is linear.
And what you'll get is you'll
get the [INAUDIBLE] again,
dJ d alpha-- i is not
a random variable.
So pull that out.
dJ d alpha i, again the sum z--
sorry.
Expectation of zi then z1.
Now, this sum goes
through all the i's.
But the first one only
has that z1, right?
Now, zi, z1, they're
independent, mean 0.
So you can sort
of split these up,
and you're going to get that
they're 0 for every term,
except for the term
where i equals 1,
and the second one where
equals 2, et cetera, right?
All the other terms
are going to go to 0.
So it's easy, then.
To get the expectations,
you go through the sum,
and you're going to
see that you only
have the one where you have
expectation of z1 squared,
expectation of z2 squared.
Now, the expectation-- again,
maybe you remember variance
equals expected value of x
squared minus expected value
of x squared, right?
Now, we're mean 0, so this is 0.
Our variance is sigma
squared, So our expected value
of x squared is sigma squared.
So that means that each
one of these expectations
is going to be sigma squared.
So you're going to end up where
you have negative eta-- now,
they all the same sigma,
so we can pull that out--
sigma squared.
And you're going to have the
vector of this dJ d alpha 1,
dJ d alpha 2, et cetera.
So you're going
to get dJ d alpha.
So yeah, so the
expectation, this update,
when we look at it in
this sort of linear sense,
is eta sigma squared-- so
just these are scalars.
They just change
the magnitude of it.
But it's in the direction
of the gradient.
And eta is sort
of our parameter.
We can control it.
That makes sense?
AUDIENCE: Is that sigma squared?
JOHN W. ROBERTS: Yes, yes.
Sorry.
Yeah, sorry.
Yeah.
So the noise you
use pops out here.
Comment-- I actually oftentimes
in one of the other--
when we look at this
algorithm in a different way,
they write the
update where it's eta
over sigma squared, your noise.
And then that cancels
out that sigma squared,
and you purely just
get eta dJ d alpha.
So you can put that in, too,
if you wanted to really just be
eta times your true gradient.
But the important
thing is that you'll
move an expectation
in the true direction.
So a couple of interesting
properties to this.
Here, you see we
still have to do--
we still have to do two
evaluations to give rid
of the update, right?
If we want to cancel
out that J alpha term,
we're going to have
to evaluate it twice.
Now, it doesn't matter
for three-dimensional,
and we only have to
evaluate it twice.
But we still have to
evaluate it two times.
And the question is,
well, what happens if you
don't evaluate it at J alpha?
What happens if you
only evaluate it once?
Well, that's a very common
thing to do, actually,
and doesn't actually affect
your expectation at all.
Lots of times,
instead of this sort
of like your perfect baseline
where you evaluate it,
people sometimes average
the last several evaluations
to get that
baseline-- oh, sorry.
I don't think I
defined baseline.
This right here, whatever
it is, is your baseline.
Now, there doesn't
have to be J of alpha.
It can be an exponentially
decaying average
of your last
several evaluations.
That's going be
approximately J of alpha.
And it won't be
perfect, but the point
is that it's not
going to affect it,
and we're going to see that.
Maybe you'd expect that you
need to get rid of that term
for you're still moving in the
direction [? of ?] [? your ?]
gradient, because you can
imagine if you don't have that,
if you don't know that
term, you could evaluate--
if it's always
positive, you'll--
I'll draw a diagram,
make this clear.
If you don't have that, and
you're here, if I-- let's say
I just make that 0.
I'm going to
evaluate here, that's
going to be a positive number.
So I'm moving in the
opposite direction.
If I evaluate here, it's
going to be positive number.
So you're going to move
in the opposite direction.
So maybe you think like,
oh, without that baseline
we could be in bad shape.
But actually, you'll move
more in this direction
when you do that sample than
you move in this direction
when you do the other sample.
And so that scale
here, the fact that you
move proportional to how big
the change is in your cost,
it means that in
expectation, you'll
still move in the direction
of the true gradient.
Now, in practice you
won't do as well.
It makes sense that
you won't do as well.
Really, when you
think about it, that's
going to be bouncing
all around crazily.
But it'll still move in
the direction the gradient.
And you don't just have
to take my word for that.
If you look at
this update again,
now we can do linear
expansion again,
and you'll get this dJ d alpha
z plus, say, some scalar--
this is uncorrelated
with the noise.
That's an important
thing, though.
It's uncorrelated
with the noise z.
Now, use expectation again.
Expectation is linear.
So we have expectation
of this term.
That's the same
as it was before.
That's the gradient.
And then we have expectation
of negative eta dz.
Now, E is uncorrelated
with the noise.
These are both scalar, so you
can actually pull them out.
Expectation of z, it's mean 0.
So this won't affect it at all.
So really, your expected update
will not depend it all on what
you use here.
So you could put
a constant there.
You could put in the exact one.
You could put in some decaying
average, anything you want.
It will still move,
in expectation,
in the right direction.
But in practice, it
can a huge difference.
I don't know if anyone's
implemented these things on--
but a good baseline can be
the difference between success
and getting completely stuck
and not moving anywhere.
So if you do small updates,
you should still be OK.
But performance depends a
lot on getting a baseline.
Or it can depend a lot.
Sometimes it doesn't matter.
Right.
So the-- yeah.
So again, a common thing to use
here is that you're evaluating,
you're updating.
Let's say every time I do
one evaluation, I update.
If I took my last 10 of
them, I averaged them
with decaying sort of weight
so that the most recent one
is the most heavily
weighted, then
I'm sure you'll get an
approximation of how much
should it be around here.
And then I update based on that.
And that way you don't have to
evaluate it twice every time.
And so that way,
you can actually
get sort of improved
performance.
And it's still going to work.
And another cool
thing, this is sort
of when we go back
to our assumptions
about deterministic.
It doesn't have to be
deterministic, either.
Let's say in the same way
we put in this, instead
let's say we put in noise like,
again, like a scalar noise
to evaluation w.
Oh, I just got [? color. ?]
Now, that's going to
show up in here again.
Now, it's not a--
now it's a random variable,
so it has an expectation.
But if they're uncorrelated,
we can split them up.
We can-- that'll be equal to
negative eta expectation w
expectation z.
Now, we know that
z is mean 0 again.
That's 0.
So it's not going
to affect either.
We're still going
to get this term.
And so you can add sort
of additive random noise,
and you'll still move that
through expected direction,
the gradient.
So that's sort of cool.
This is quite robust.
You can have these
errors in this baseline.
You can have noisy evaluations.
You can have all
sorts of these things.
And still, expectation will
move in the right direction.
So that's nice.
We're going to see that that
has a lot of practical benefits.
Is everybody with me here?
I don't know if I went
through this quickly or if--
everyone's sort of being quiet.
They look sort of--
AUDIENCE: w is baseline there?
JOHN W. ROBERTS: No, no, sorry.
This w I change it to noise.
Sorry, this is a noise.
Maybe you'd prefer it to be
called like xi or something
like that.
But this is just added noise.
So you could say that
z is drawn from--
it doesn't really
matter the distribution
as long as it's uncorrelated.
We could say it's drawn
from some other Gaussian.
And so it's expectation--
I mean, expectation of
this really can be 0, too.
Because if it's not non-zero--
it's not mean 0 noise,
then you might as well just
put that in your cost function
and make it mean 0 again, right?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So the idea is to
add this into the term J alpha?
Or replace the term J alpha
with different baseline?
JOHN W. ROBERTS:
Replace it, right.
AUDIENCE: OK.
And then so what
cancels-- so when we
talk about a Taylor expansion?
What cancels-- what--
JOHN W. ROBERTS: Nothing.
Nothing cancels it.
You see, that's the thing.
Yeah, so I put an E here--
maybe I'm reusing
too many things.
AUDIENCE: Oh, is it J alpha
is also uncorrelated to z?
JOHN W. ROBERTS:
Well, J alpha, J alpha
is just a scalar, right?
I mean, it is some number.
So it is--
AUDIENCE: z is your mean, so.
JOHN W. ROBERTS: Yeah,
so z is your mean.
So whether-- we
could put in J alpha.
We could put an estimate of
J alpha that has some error.
And then our J
alpha minus this is
going to be some
number-- doesn't matter.
If we just put in
nothing at all, then
our error is sort of
that J alpha term.
That J alpha term
is just, again,
some number that's
uncorrelated, gets rid of it.
Does that make sense?
Everyone looks sort of just--
AUDIENCE: So it's actually,
putting another constant
in that equation for the
update makes you move more
in some random z-direction.
But on average, you're still
going down the gradient
the same way.
JOHN W. ROBERTS: Yeah.
I mean, you can move more.
Yeah.
I mean, if you put some-- if
you put some giant constant
every time you update, maybe
you'll bounce around farther.
But on average, you'll still
move in the right direction.
Because you'll move farther in
the right direction than you
move in the wrong direction.
So they sort of cancel out.
So everybody is on board here?
OK.
I just really want you to--
AUDIENCE: Why wouldn't you
include the actual J alpha?
JOHN W. ROBERTS: Well,
because if you get it
by evaluating the function,
if you run a policy,
it can be expensive to
get that J alpha, right?
Because for example, I
use this in some work
I did where we had
this flapping thing.
I'll show you videos of it.
Maybe I'll start setting
that up right now.
But so we have this
flapping system.
And we get-- we sort
of have souped it
up now so it's a bit quicker.
But it used to be
every time I wanted
to evaluate the function, I
had to sit there for 4 minutes
and have this sort of
plate flap in this water
and measure how quickly it
was going, all these things.
And so to evaluate that function
once, it took me 4 minutes.
And so avoiding
evaluations is important.
And so if you can just take your
several previous evaluations,
average them
together-- now, it's
not going to be a
perfect assignment,
but maybe it's an OK
estimate, and then
you don't have to
spend any more time.
And so in that sense,
it's sort of cheaper.
Please ask as many questions
as possible, because this is--
AUDIENCE: But at some point
you have to measure every time,
right?
JOHN W. ROBERTS: You have to.
Yeah, you have to
measure every time
when you want to do an update.
But the thing is that--
here.
Let's say i, a tiny one--
but the question is, if I
have some estimate of that--
let's say my current
sort of alpha is here.
Now, I need to randomly
sample something,
so I have to do that evaluation.
Now, the question is, do I
have to evaluate it here, too?
Because this is my J alpha.
Do I evaluate that?
Now, I could estimate
this, because have
a bunch of other evaluations
from however I got here, right?
So I've already evaluated.
If I average those
together, I'll
get a pretty good
idea of what this is.
If I wanted to get
it exactly, I'd
have to run my system here,
and then run it again here.
And so every update would
require two evaluations
as opposed to just one.
Now, sometimes it
still makes sense
to do that evaluation, though.
Depending on how your system
is, if it's really noisy,
if you have to do really
big updates, it makes sense.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] using
this delta alpha would you
calculate [INAUDIBLE]?
JOHN W. ROBERTS:
Pardon [INAUDIBLE]??
AUDIENCE: Yes.
JOHN W. ROBERTS: I'm sorry,
I didn't hear what you said.
AUDIENCE: This new
alpha that we have,
that we have the
[INAUDIBLE] before--
JOHN W. ROBERTS: This one?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: You calculate it
by having a previous alpha,
and then we did
this thing, and--
JOHN W. ROBERTS: And I moved
in that direction, right.
AUDIENCE: Right.
But you're saying that you
don't want to calculate
the value for this new alpha.
Instead we use
like, for example,
10 past history of J of alpha,
and use that as your estimate.
JOHN W. ROBERTS: Yeah.
You're saying that
doesn't make sense to you?
AUDIENCE: It does make sense.
In some cases I can think
[INAUDIBLE] actually
[INAUDIBLE] if the change--
a small change in alpha would
have a huge effect on the end
value [INAUDIBLE] from J--
like, if you have a very
discrete-- like, [INAUDIBLE]
condition pass over [INAUDIBLE].
JOHN W. ROBERTS: If you
move very violently, yeah.
So I mean, that's a good
example in practice.
I mean, there's
things that we have
in the theory like
this expectation stuff.
And there's things that I've
applied to several systems.
And in practice, when you
have like sort of really
bad policies, and you need
to move really far in state
space-- let's say
that right now you're
trying to swing up a cart-pole,
and you're not going anywhere
near the top.
And your reward function doesn't
have very smooth gradients,
and so you can't just sort of
swing up a bit by bit by bit.
Well, a good thing is, is to
put in place possibly very
big noise, a very big eta, and
then do these two evaluations.
Because if you-- it's going
to change so much every time
you do it.
Like for example, if you
jump and suddenly you're
doing a lot better, then
your previous average
is not going to
be representative.
And then you can
actually bounce around.
You can bounce
around so violently
in this big space of policies
that you never improve, right?
I don't-- maybe I should draw
a diagram to make this more
clear, what I'm saying.
But the key thing
is, is that, yeah,
if you're moving these
really big jumps,
and your cost is changing
a lot every time,
and you still want to sort of
move in the right direction,
doing two evaluations
can make sense.
Because if you're
stuck to where you
don't have good gradients
in your cost function,
a bunch of little updates
which slowly would climb
aren't going to give you
anything, because maybe they're
not even differentiable.
Maybe you have some sort of
discrete way of measuring
a reward, like how many time
steps you spend in some goal
region, or something, and
you don't have any time steps
there, there's no
gradient at all right now.
And so you need to be violent
enough in sort of your policy
changes that you
eventually get it to where
you're into that goal region.
And once you get in
that goal region,
now you have some gradients
and you're in good shape.
So that's actually another thing
that I was going to talk about.
But designing your cost
function is extremely important.
There are cost functions
that can be extremely poor
and doing this can
work really poorly on.
And there's cost functions
that can make it a lot easier.
So if you have a cost function
which is relatively smooth,
if it's-- ideally it doesn't
have this sort of banana
problem.
If it's relatively same in
all the different parameters,
it can work a lot better.
And you can sort of formulate
the same task lots of time,
since lots of times your cost
function isn't what you really
want to optimize.
It's just of a proxy for
trying to get something done.
That's what Russ talked about
he didn't care about optimality.
It's like, here's a
cost function that
gives us a means of
solving how to do this.
And so there's sort of a
whole bunch of cost functions
you can imagine coming up that
try to encapsulate that task.
Now, if you come up with-- for
the perch one, for example,
this plane perching, which
is a difficult problem,
and a problem where the
models are very bad--
I mean, the aerodynamic
models of this plane
flying like that
are extremely poor.
And we have-- we actually
have some decent ones.
We spent a lot of work
trying to get decent ones.
But sort of the
high-fidelity kind of region,
where you really want
to just get at the end,
it's hard to model that.
So the thing is that,
what if you had a cost
function, like what
we really care about
is hitting that perch.
So let's say that we give
you a 1 if you hit the perch
and a 0 everywhere else.
Now, that means until
we hit the perch,
we're getting no information.
We could be getting
really close,
we could be really far away.
It's not going to
tell us anything.
Now, a lot of actually
reinforcement learning
has these sort of rewards, like
these sort of delayed rewards
where you get it
here, and then you
have to sort of
propagate that back.
When you're trying to
accomplish a task like that,
that doesn't necessarily
work that well.
If you measure
something like distance
from the perch of distance
from your desired state,
if you get a little bit
closer to your desired state,
you sort of get a
little bit better.
And then you can
measure the gradient.
And so that will make a
big difference, right?
And so if you had
something where
you have region
of state where you
have a good gradient
in your cost function,
and you're out here, and
not getting a gradient,
the little perturbations
you're going
to have to random walk
sort of have made you
no update at all, because
you may get no change.
But if you do really
big ones, maybe you'll
bounce into where you
get this region where
you're getting some reward.
And in that case,
these updates are
so big that averaging
doesn't make sense,
a baseline still gives
you a big advantage,
and maybe two
evaluations is worth it.
In some of the
flapping stuff I did,
I did two evaluations,
because when
I was moving very
violently, because averaging
didn't work that well.
And getting a good baseline
was worth the extra time.
But when we ended up
getting it working,
we put it online, and we
actually-- we update it
every time we flapped.
So it was just 1 second,
flap, update, flap, update.
And that way, we
pretty much were
able to sort of cut our time in
half, because our policies were
very similar, our average
was a pretty good estimate.
It's so noisy that one
evaluation, anyway,
isn't necessarily that great of
an estimate of your local value
function.
And so yeah.
We just did an average baseline.
And that's sort of half
the running time, right?
And so it can be a big one.
And so there's a lot of
details when you implement it
about the right way to
sort of put this together,
and depending what your cost
function is, and how good
of an initial policy, what
your initial condition
and your policy is.
But yeah, there's a lot
of factors like that.
All right.
So now we can do some of--
sorry.
I can do example of this.
So I keep on talking about
this flapping system.
That's what I worked on
for my master's thesis.
And so that's sort of what
my brain always goes back to,
particularly since we
used all these methods.
But all right.
So now I wonder if I
can do Russ' thing where
he makes the font really big.
That's also-- the
thing I'm about to run,
it's this relatively simple
lumped parameter simulation
of the flapping system.
This is a lumped parameter
model of-- let me show you,
it's pretty cool--
of this system which I guy
in NYU named Jun [? Zhang ?]
built this robot that
effectively models flapping
flight.
It's a very simple model.
I'll show it to you in a second.
But it has a lot of
the same dynamics
and a lot of the same
issues as sort of a bird.
So the system, it's a
sort of a rigid plate.
Well, the one you see here, we
attached a rubber tail to it.
But the one-- most
of these results
are on actually a rigid plate,
where it heaves up and down,
and what we can do is control
the motion it follows.
I hope that the
camera can see it.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
moonlight [INAUDIBLE]..
JOHN W. ROBERTS: Mood?
AUDIENCE: Moonlight.
JOHN W. ROBERTS: Oh, moonlight.
I was like, mood lighting?
OK.
Make my lecture more enjoyable.
All right.
So this is the system.
You can see we drive
it up and down.
That big cylindrical disk
right there is the load cell.
So that measures the
force we're applying.
And then what we do is we
control this vertical motion.
How we control it is--
that's an important thing.
I talked about how the cost
function matters a lot.
Well, another thing
that matters a lot
is the parameterization
of your policy.
Now, in the last few problems
we had open-loop policies,
which are pretty simple.
You have like 251 parameters
or something like that, right?
Now, when you're doing
gradient descent using back
prop or SNOPT, you have
the exact gradient.
It's cheap to compute
the exact gradient,
so you can sort of follow
this pretty nicely.
But When you do stochastic
gradient descent,
the probability of
being perpendicular sort
of to your gradient, or nearly
perpendicular to the gradient,
increases the number
of parameters goes up.
So you can think, if you're on--
if you're doing a
1D thing, you're
always going to move
pretty much-- it doesn't
matter if you move in
the right direction
or the wrong direction.
That's one of the benefits
of this instead of that hill
climbing.
But you're always trying to get
moving in the right direction
to get this measurement.
Does that make sense?
If you think in 2D,
you have the circle.
You're going to
be moving around.
You're going to be along--
close to the direction of
your gradient pretty often.
A sphere, it's a lot easier
to be pretty far away.
I mean, sort of a lot
more of the samples you do
are going to be
relatively perpendicular
to your true gradient.
And as your dimensionality
gets very high,
a lot of your samples are
relatively perpendicular.
And the thing is
that whether you
go in the right direction or
wrong direction doesn't matter.
You'll get the same
information either way.
Going perpendicular
to the gradient
gives you no information.
Because you'll get no change,
and there's no update.
So it's still-- the
[? cross ?] dimensionality
is alive and well.
And very
high-dimensional policies
can be slower to learn.
And so those 251
dimensional policies you use
may not be the best
representation,
because they sort of--
I mean, you probably don't
need that many parameters
to represent what
you want to do.
So for this, what we had--
and this made a
big difference, we
tried different things, this
one worked really nicely--
was a spline.
So we said, all right,
if you have time,
I'm going to set
the final time here.
Now that's a parameter, too.
Then this is the z height.
It's in millimeters
or whatever you want.
And I'm going to
say, OK, I'm going
to force it to be at the
beginning, in the middle,
and at the end-- wow, that's
nowhere near the middle, is it?
I shouldn't be a
carpenter in the 1200s.
So what do we do then?
We then have five
parameters-- now, we've
done several versions, but
simple one right here-- five
parameters that define a spline.
So this is going to be smooth.
You can enforce to be a
periodic spline, which
means that the knot at the
end, the connection here, is
continuously
differentiable as well.
And then we force that this
parameter-- so this number p1,
this one is going to
be the opposite of it.
So it's a negative p1.
And that's true for all these.
So this way, we have this
relatively rich policy class
that has sort of the
right kind of properties.
But we do it with
only five parameters.
So you can imagine,
if we want it
to be asymmetric top
and bottom, that would
double our parameters.
And we probably wouldn't
want to tie this guy to 0,
so we'd even add one more.
And when we have
the amplitude, you
can either fix it
or make it free.
I can add another parameter.
So you can see that as
you add this richness,
you're going to add all
these different parameters.
But getting-- using a
spline rather than--
this is the height right now,
this is the height right then--
it's a huge advantage.
Because what's the
chance that you're
going to want it to move very
violently on a sort of like 1
dt time scale?
And if you try to do
that, you could actually
damage your system.
Some of the policies
that I-- when
I was working on this
parameterization,
I had the load cell break off
and fall into the tank once.
Luckily it broke off
the wires and lost
its electric connection before
it fell in there, but yeah.
So if you come up with
a parameterization that
appropriately captures the kind
of behaviors you expect to see,
it can be a lot faster to learn.
Now, sort of the warning,
then, is that you're only
going to be optimal--
the only thing, you're going get
to a local minimum in this sort
of parameterization space.
So if you parameterize-- if
I were to parameterize this
by saying, OK, well I'm only
going to let it be some--
let's say I was going to do like
a Fourier series kind of thing
and say, OK, it's add
this, this, and this--
now, that's not very rich.
It's only three parameters.
That's good.
But I'm going to do all sorts
of things that are probably
extremely sub-optimal.
Now, it's still going to find
the best kind of behavior,
or the locally best
kind of behavior
can using this kind of policy.
But it could be quite bad.
So the actual optimum
could be very different.
So your policy class, you'd
like it to include the optimum.
And so that sort
of is-- it depends
on what the question is.
You sort of have to just have a
feel for what is a good policy
class.
How do I get [? my ?]
dimension as low as possible,
while still having the richness
to represent a wide variety
of viable policies?
So when you're trying to
implement these things,
that can make a big difference.
So yeah.
So we set up that.
And we could control
the shape of that curve.
And so that is the policy
parameterization we chose.
So going back to this code here.
Now, I think I can
just run this here.
This is going to be doing
that bit we talked about on--
again, a simple lumped parameter
model of that flapping system.
So here's our curve.
It's this, you see
this-- well, this
is the forward motion of
the thing as it's flapping.
This is the vertical motion.
So this is sort of the
waveform it's following.
This is where it
is in x position.
You can see it sort of
goes fast, bounces around--
sorry, this is the
speed, not the position.
So you can see it
accelerates from 0,
and then as it's pumping,
it sort of oscillates a bit.
In practice, there's more
inertia and everything,
so you don't see these
high-frequency oscillations.
But this is just a relatively
simple, explicit model.
This is the shape we follow.
So we're following that curve.
And we have a little
bit of noise to it.
And let me-- so now we're going
to perturb it, measure again.
Try to measure again,
and boom, here we are.
We got a little bit better.
This is our reward, and
then we did another sample,
and that's our reward.
Let's do it again, better.
You see we improve quite nicely.
And also, notice,
relatively monotonically.
Now, you might be
surprised by that.
Because even though
we're moving--
we have this sort
of guarantee we'll
move within 90 degrees
of the gradient.
That's what I was talking
about sort of with,
you'll always be within 90
degrees if it's deterministic.
And this is deterministic.
But it also sort of is this
linear kind of interpretation,
right?
So as you run it, you'd imagine
that you could perturb yourself
far enough that you got worse.
Now, the reason
that's not happening
is because I'm perturbing
myself very small amounts,
and I'm updating
very small amounts.
So all this sort of linear
analysis is appropriate.
And actually, you can see
what I talked about that,
that you always get pretty close
to the true gradient is there.
Sometimes it moves up a
lot, sometimes it's steep,
sometimes it moves up shallowly,
but it does a pretty good job.
Now, we can change that and
try to sabotage our little code
here.
Or sometimes you're
OK, actually.
That's the thing, is that
in practice lots of times
it's OK if it gets
worse sometimes,
because allowing
it to get worse,
being violent
enough to get worse,
it'll reach the
optimum a lot faster.
So here, this is
our eta parameter.
Let's make it bigger a factor
of-- let's make it 20.5.
I don't want to risk--
[INAUDIBLE] not get worse.
AUDIENCE: Is that the noise or--
JOHN W. ROBERTS: Pardon?
No, that is the update.
So the noise is the same.
This noise is still local.
But now we're
jumping really far.
And so you can imagine,
we're measuring the gradient.
We're moving really far.
And now where we've
moved to, that gradient
may be a poor
measurement of sort
of the update over
that long of a scale.
So let's do this again.
This is always fun.
Oh, there you go, already.
That's better.
See now-- but you see,
that's a huge increase then.
That's what I'm talking
about, is that there's
sort of a sweet spot.
And you don't necessarily
want monotonic increasing.
Like, there's limitations
on how violent
you want it to be in
practice, because on a robot,
a very violent policy
could break your load
cell of and have it
almost cost you $400.
So you don't do something crazy.
But there's also the willingness
that-- oh, that's ugly.
But you see, I mean, if
you bounce pretty far,
you can also get
huge improvements.
And so there's sort of this--
monotonicity in your
increasing reward
is not necessarily the best
way to learn, I suppose.
That's from the trenches.
I learned that the hard way
through many, many hours
sitting in front of a machine.
So then the other thing
that we can do is this eta.
Let's decrease eta.
And now let's make
our sigma really big.
Now, this is going to be
really crazy stuff probably.
But you see, now we're
going to measure so far.
And we're going to
get this sort of--
we're going to try to
measure the gradient,
but it's going to be just
way off, because it's
moving so far that the local
structure is completely
ignored.
Yeah.
I probably don't have to be
nearly as dramatic as this
to make my point.
But, you know, it's just
completely falling apart.
Yeah.
That's doing as badly
as it can, I guess.
I think it's like almost
[? no net ?] motion, so.
Yeah.
So the sweet spot,
then, is somewhere in
between, where maybe you
want an eta of, say, 3,
and sigma, I don't know, 0.1.
Oh, that's probably
still too violent.
Yeah, definitely.
But I think that is--
that's the sort of
game you have to play.
And how big all these things are
depend on a number of factors
specific to your system.
Like, if your system--
if the change is very
small in magnitude,
if your cost function
is such that it's
changed between 10 to
the negative fifth and 10
to the negative
fifth plus 1 times 10
to the negative sixth, that's
changing by very small amounts,
right?
You could need a very large eta
just to make up for the fact
that your change is so small.
So a big eta-- like, there's
no absolute perception
on what is a big eta.
It's not like 10,000
is a huge eta.
10,000 could be very
small eta, depending
on what your rewards are.
Same thing with sigma.
It depends on how big
your parameters are.
Because, I mean,
my parameters here
are of order one, which
is sort of convenient.
Yeah.
So there.
So here we're learning
pretty quickly.
And so all those sort
of things, that's
sort of a disadvantage
of this technique,
is that there's a lot of tuning
to sort solve these things,
is that--
where SNOPT you
don't have to set--
SNOPT you don't have
to set a learning rate,
here you have to
set a learning rate.
You have to set your sigma.
And when you have really
sort of hard problems,
there's even more
things you have to do.
Like, your policy
parameterization
could affect a lot of things.
There's a lot of issues.
But sometimes, that's--
sometimes it's the only sort
of route you have.
Like, the best this can
ever do is gradient descent.
It's never going to do
better than gradient descent.
And so there's of a lot of
fancy packages out there.
When you have better
models and stuff like that,
you can do better
than gradient descent.
But while even
though you're only
going to be able to
achieve gradient descent,
you can achieve it
despite the fact
that you know nothing
about your system,
your system is stochastic,
and it's noisy, like that.
And so in those cases,
it can be a big win.
AUDIENCE: So when you were
doing this in real life,
instead of in space
each time, you
were sitting for 4 minutes
in front of a flapping--
JOHN W. ROBERTS: I automated
pretty much everything, yeah.
So I was-- but yeah.
I mean, this is a
little simulation.
AUDIENCE: Every interval was
like actually it running and--
JOHN W. ROBERTS: Oh, yeah.
When I pressed
Space, it actually
does two-- because this
is using a true baseline.
I didn't put in the
average baseline.
So this is running it twice
every time I press Space.
But yeah.
You can imagine every
time I'm doing Space,
it does this one update and
gives me that new point.
What I was doing is I sat
there, and it would run,
and I'd babysit to make
sure it wasn't broken.
And it would throw
up the curve as it
was running so I could make sure
that the encoders weren't off,
just sort of sitting
there keeping
track of all these things.
I was like a nuclear
safety technician.
I just eat some doughnuts and
go to Moe's, and I would have
been a good sitcom character.
But yeah.
So I mean, pretty much
just babysitting it.
But yeah, every time you
did it, every time you
got a new update-- like,
every one of these points
cost me 6 minutes or
something, because it
was like a 3-minute
run for-- basically
a 3-minute run for an update.
Because I wasn't using
averaged baseline then either.
I was trying to be more violent.
But yeah.
And so that's the
thing, is that that
is the perfect
encapsulation of why
you want to use this information
as carefully as possible.
It's because it's very
expensive to get a point.
Like, here it cost nothing.
If I were to turn
off the pause, like,
this thing would
climb up like that.
If you're running
on a robot, like we
want to use this on the
glider, every time you watch
that glider, you have
to set up the glider,
fire it off, take all this
data, and reset it by hand,
and launch it again.
So getting a data point there
is going be extremely expensive.
And so we've actually done
some work on the right ways
to sample.
You can imagine trying to
come up with the right ways
to have a policy.
But sampling intelligently
can save you a lot of time.
We sort of look at the
signal-to-noise ratio
of these updates.
I don't know if anyone--
some people here probably at
least heard about that stuff
since they're in my group.
But probably talk about
that maybe tomorrow.
But there's these
things you can do
that can improve the quality
of your performance a lot.
And actually, I test
on this exact system.
I got put on the
system, and I ran it
with the sort of results
we had that's just,
this is a better way to
sample, and then just
with a naive Gaussian kind of
sampling, and you learn faster.
And in the context of me sitting
there and spending my days
in New York City huddled in
front of a computer, that's
a big win.
So anyway.
AUDIENCE: So when you
say change the sampling,
you can just change the
variance like you would do
to a non-Gaussian distribution?
JOHN W. ROBERTS: Right, yeah.
So that-- yeah.
In fact, we used a very
different kind of description
overall.
You can still-- the linear
analysis will still work.
But it's just a local--
but yeah, there's work
where they change--
We also have something where
you change the variance
[? to ?] the Gaussian, but
your different directions
have different variances.
And so if you sort of need
an estimate of the gradient,
then--
but you just estimate the
gradient to bias your sampling
more in the directions where
you think the gradient is, so
that more of your sampling is
along the directions you think
are most interesting.
And so that can be a win when
you have a lot of parameters
that aren't well correlated.
Like if you imagine
if you had a feedback
policy that was dependent on--
a parameter is active
in a certain state--
like, if I was at negative
2 to negative 5, I do this,
and let's say I
never get there, then
that parameter has nothing to
do with how well I perform.
And so if you know
that, you can sort
of-- there's something called
an eligibility you can track.
And you cannot update
that parameter.
There's no reason to
sort of be fooling around
with that parameter when it's
not affecting your output.
And if you know that, you
can do things like that.
And we sort of have a way,
a more careful way of,
shaping all these--
of shaping this Gaussian
to learn faster.
And it can.
And also, just completely very
different kind of sampling.
Like, it's-- well, maybe
I'll try to talk about it.
Because I think it's
pretty interesting stuff.
The math is a little
bit nasty, but I'll
skip the really ugly steps.
And actually, the one with
the different distribution
isn't even that nasty.
But yeah.
I mean, we ran it here and
it [INAUDIBLE] improvement.
Yeah, so.
Did I answer your question?
Yeah.
It's not just changing
the variances.
It's more complicated than that.
Although changing the
variances can be a big win.
For example, if you knew
you had this anisotropy,
and if you were to have
different etas in different--
if you were to scale
everything in your sigma,
you could effectively make
it squashed in, right?
I mean, just a rescaling
of this anisotropic bowl
will make it right.
So if you can evaluate
that, you can fix it.
But you sort have to know
that that's going on.
That's about the times
you have adaptive
learning rates and stuff.
Gradient descent, like if you
keep moving the same direction,
you have a bigger learning rate.
You can have different
learning rates,
you have different parameters.
This one, as you get
close to a local min,
you'll decrease your
learning rate and your noise,
because you want to
sort of bounce around.
You don't want to be
jumping all across this min.
So--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] talked
about a basically policy
gradient when we
were [INAUDIBLE]..
JOHN W. ROBERTS: Yeah, no.
Yeah.
I mean, there is--
it's definitely exactly that.
It's just stochastic gradient.
But yeah, it's all
policy gradient ideas.
Because we don't-- I mean, these
things don't have a critic,
right?
But you can combine this
with some policy evaluation
techniques.
And you can turn them into
actor-critic algorithms.
A very simple-- do people know
about actor-critic algorithms?
That's going to be
a subject I think
Russ talks about at the end.
But the thing is that
right now-- well, I'll
motivate in a completely
different way.
We talked about how
this baseline can affect
your performance a lot, right?
Now, a good baseline can
make you do a lot better.
Now, the thing is
that, what happens
if-- here we start with the same
initial condition every time.
But let's say that I
actually could be in one
of two initial conditions.
I can measure this,
and then I run it.
And the system behaves
very differently,
or the costs are very
different depending
on my initial condition.
But I want sort of the same
policy to cover both of these.
So the thing is, if I just did
this and I had one baseline
for both of them, and I could
randomly be putting these
in [? different initial ?]
conditions or whatever--
or I mean, I could--
there's probably a more
sensible way of saying this,
but I don't want to
confuse the issue.
So if you could have
different initial conditions,
you can make your
baseline a function
of your initial condition.
Does that makes sense?
Instead of just having B,
instead of evaluating it twice,
I could have my B of x.
And if my x is here,
I'm going to say, OK,
my cost should be like this.
And if my x is here,
then it's like, oh,
my cost should be like this.
And when I evaluate my cost,
when I perturb my policy,
I have a better idea
of how well I'm doing.
Does that makes sense?
It probably doesn't, so.
All right.
So let's say-- now,
this is phase space now.
Now let's say that I can
start in either of these.
And let's say that
I'm trying to get to--
let's draw this here.
I'm trying to get to 0.
That's my goal.
And I can measure this.
But then one of them, I'm
going to go [WHOOSH] like that.
And the other one I'm going
to have to go, I don't know,
through whatever
torque, [? limited ?]
reasons like that or something.
So this one always costs more
than this one, all right?
It doesn't matter how
good my policy is.
Like, you can imagine just
have a feedback policy.
It doesn't matter how bad
it is, how good it is.
I mean, the same policy is
always going to do worse here.
Now, if you believe that a good
baseline improves performance--
and trust me, it does--
then I don't want
the same baseline.
I don't want the same B for
both of these situations.
Because this guy should
always be around 50,
and this guy should always
be around 20, right?
So what I could
do is I could have
my baseline be a function of x.
And I'm going to be like,
OK, here my baseline is 50,
here my baseline is 20.
And let's say I don't
know that from the start.
I can learn my baseline
while I'm learning my policy.
So I can use the same
policy for both situations.
And then over here
I measure my state,
and I'm like, oh, over here
I'm doing bad all the time.
So my baseline is
going to be high.
And over here I'm
always doing well,
so my baseline is
going to be low.
And so in that way you can
take that into account.
Does that makes sense?
it does look like--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] this
is basically Monte-Carlo
sampling and learning.
Because each time
that you set your--
so your policy is defined
by a set of alphas.
And then you fix it,
you run it, and you
get a sample that says what
is the value associated
with this starting point
given this [INAUDIBLE] policy.
JOHN W. ROBERTS: Are you
talking about Monte-Carlo
for policy evaluation?
Because Monte-Carlo [INAUDIBLE].
That's like TD infinity
or whatever it is.
And that's for
policy evaluation.
That's how you make a critic.
The policy is different, right?
The policy, you're
doing this update,
then you're advancing it a bit.
Your critic, the
way I just described
making the baseline
for this, that would be
a Monte-Carlo interpretation.
You could do it with t, lambda,
or anything you wanted to.
But yeah.
So the important thing is--
I mean, it looks like
the sort of blank faces
after I talked about that.
But Russ, I think, is going
to go into more detail
into actor-critic.
But maybe I can talk about
that more tomorrow if you want.
Yeah.
I mean, the important thing
is that right now this
is a very simple kind of
idea we've talked about,
where you run the alpha, and
then if you ran the same alpha,
it would always do the same.
Or maybe it just has a
little bit of additive noise.
But If actually running the same
alpha from different states--
which happens a lot
in a lot of systems--
the different states could have
different expected performance.
And so while you'll still
learn without the baseline,
having a good
baseline everywhere
will make you learn faster.
And so it's worth
learning a baseline
and learning the
policy simultaneously.
And sort of the thing we
talked about, where you just
average your last several
samples to get your baseline,
that's already we're
learning a baseline, right?
We're just learning it for
everywhere in state space.
We're saying this is the
same everywhere, right?
AUDIENCE: That idea
of sampling, can you
do something like [? smarter ?]
using Gaussian processes
to do active
learning on top of it
to sample in areas that
are more promising?
Instead of just randomly
moving somewhere?
JOHN W. ROBERTS:
I mean, there are
ways of biasing your
sampling based on what
you think the gradient is.
I mean, that's one of
the things we worked on
with signal-to-noise ratio.
I'm not sure exactly what--
AUDIENCE: I know some people
worked on Aibos walking,
and they wanted to
find a gain which
maximizes the speed of the
Aibos when they're walking.
JOHN W. ROBERTS: I think
I read that paper, yeah.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, and there
are like 12 or 13 dimensions.
And it seems like
a similar problem--
JOHN W. ROBERTS:
No, I think they
use a very similar algorithm.
I think they had a
different update, though.
It was the same kind of idea.
I think that the update
structure was maybe
different than that.
Yeah.
So I won't dwell
on critic stuff.
That's, I think, the
last lecture in the class
or something like that.
But yeah.
So here, I mean, this is
sort of the sample system.
And you can see how this thing
is robust to really noisy
systems in practice.
Because when I ran it on the
flapping thing down at NYU,
the consecutive evaluations
could be very different--
not because of any
change in policy,
You run the same policy,
you get a big variance.
So that's just
because you're running
on this physical robot
with this fluid system
and you're measuring the
forces in an analog sensor.
And so it's just very noisy.
But it's robust to that.
And that's what's so nice.
Put that here.
So look at that.
I mean, this one--
these, luckily,
didn't take 3 minutes anymore.
They took 1 second.
So it wasn't nearly as bad.
But, I mean, look how
much it's changing.
It's changing a significant
percentage every time, right?
AUDIENCE: These are all with
the same [? taping loop? ?]
JOHN W. ROBERTS: Yeah.
Yeah-- I mean, no, this
is playing a different--
this is learning.
So the thing is that--
I mean, I showed you how
it wasn't monotonic before.
But this, you can
run the same tape.
I mean, up there it's pretty
much running the same tape.
So up there you get an idea of
what the noise looks like when
you're running the same policy.
Right.
And so you can imagine-- yes.
AUDIENCE: Just [INAUDIBLE]
went with blue and red.
JOHN W. ROBERTS:
Oh, blue and red
are different ways of
keeping track of my baseline.
All right.
So I mean, I don't worry about
the different blue and red.
They're just sort
of an internal test
to see the right way to make
these things-- we determined
that it didn't
make a difference.
But yeah.
AUDIENCE: It looks like
the red is much smoother.
JOHN W. ROBERTS: I don't know.
It may be plotting.
I may have plotted blue on
top of red or something, too,
you know?
I don't know.
I remember we decided it didn't
make much of a difference.
Yeah.
I see what you're saying.
It does look like the
variance is a bit less,
but I don't think it was.
But these are trials
on the bottom.
So that's, every second we
sort of did another flap,
we did another update.
So this is update
from the bottom.
And yeah.
This is-- we actually have a
reward instead of cost here.
So it's going to go
up instead of down.
But yeah.
So despite the fact
this is really noisy,
despite the fact that we had
this average baseline, which
I was talking about--
so our baseline wasn't
perfect-- it still learned.
It learned pretty quickly.
I mean, 400 samples maybe
doesn't seem very good.
But that's also less
than 10 minutes.
So that's like 7 minutes.
So it in practice can
work pretty darn well.
And solving this thing
with other techniques
would be very tricky.
Well, I mean, you could build
a model like this model we have
and stuff like that, you can try
to solve it with a simulation.
That's generally how they
solve a lot of these problems,
is to do the
optimization on a model.
So there's this fly.
Jane Wang at Cornell tries
to optimize the stroke form
for a fly, like a fruit fly.
I think it's a fruit fly scale.
And so she just built a
sort of pretty fancy model
of this thing and
then simulates it.
It does the optimization on a
computational fluid dynamics
simulation.
And so that's some way
we can-- and there you
can get the gradients, you
can do all the sort of things
we've already talked about.
Because you have the model,
you can do all these things
explicitly.
But the model takes
a long time to run.
I think the optimization
took months of computer time.
So if you-- that's
the thing here,
is that the full simulation
of this system, where
it took me 1 second
to get an update,
it takes, I think,
about an hour per flap.
So an hour on a
computing cluster
to get one full safety
simulation of one flap.
And that's even the simpler one.
We're working on
other ones, too,
that have sort of
aeroelastic effects, which
are where sort of the
body deforms in response
to the fluid forces.
And simulating those
is even harder.
And so where it takes an
hour to get an update,
I can get it in a second.
And the thing is my update
is going to be noisier
and I don't get
the true gradient.
But when you can get
3,600 updates per update,
you're going to win.
I mean, I'll get
one flap in the time
takes me to optimize and sit
there for most of an hour,
you know?
So you can see in
those kind of problems,
it can be a big win, especially
when a simulation is extremely
expensive, or computing
the gradient is extremely
expensive, but you have the
robot right in front of you.
You can just take that
data, accept the noise,
do model-free gradient descent.
I think that's what I
wanted to talk about.
If you have any questions or
anything didn't make sense
at all, please let me know.
Otherwise, maybe I'll
introduce something
that I'm trying to
talk about tomorrow,
a different interpretation.
I'll just try to get your
brain ready for it, I guess.
But if there are any other
questions on this, please ask.
AUDIENCE: What was the reward
function for [INAUDIBLE]??
JOHN W. ROBERTS:
The reward function
for this was the integral of
velocity, of spin velocity,
over the integral
of power input.
So it measured the force
on it, multiplied that
by the vertical velocity.
That gives you
the rate of power.
That gives you power,
which is the rate of work.
And then it just sort of
calculates the distance.
And so that ratio is what
we tried to optimize.
So it tries to figure out sort
of the minimum energy per unit
distance.
And so it spins
around in a circle,
but it's a model of
it going forward.
So we did it for
an angle, but you
can do it just as easily for
if you had a linear test.
It's just harder experimentally.
And so it's try-- it's sort
of an efficiency metric.
Yeah?
All right.
Turn the lights back up.
Make sure I crossed all
my Ts, dotted my Is.
Oh, yeah.
And actually, there's
one story, too,
before I get into that thing.
So a lot of these
things originated,
like a lot of the things we've
seen for neural networks--
like back prop, like
gradient descent.
I mean, we learned
that [INAUDIBLE]
originated in the context of
neural networks, RTRL did.
And a lot of this did,
the reinforce algorithm,
which is the thing we're going
to talk about-- originated
with neural networks.
And one of the reasons
they found so appealing,
particularly like this
kind of stochastic work,
is that it seemed
biologically plausible.
That it could be like, what is
the chance that a human brain
is doing back prop?
I mean, it could be doing some
sort of approximate back prop
or something like that.
I actually don't know that
much about neuroscience.
But the thing is that these
sort of computationally involved
techniques for
solving these problems
don't seem like they're
reasonable as sort
of postulations on how the
human brain or how neurons solve
these problems.
But this one, you can
see, it's so simple.
And the little randomness
being part of it
and just the sort of like
simple update structure does
seem biologically plausible.
Just sort of intuitively,
it makes more sense.
But even more than that,
there's examples of--
there's data and
evidence that suggests
that these kind of things could
be one of the aspects of how
animals learn.
And the coolest one, I
think, is there's these song
birds that learn how to sing.
Like, they don't-- they're
not born knowing a certain way
to sing.
But they hear their parents
sing as they're growing up,
and they start
singing more and more.
And they get better and better.
And actually, you can hear
them getting better until they
sing like their parents did.
And you can raise
them in captivity
and play them
Elvis all the time,
and they'll do like a song
bird impression of Elvis, which
I'm surprised you can't buy the
CD of that on late night TV.
But the-- right.
But so a really
cool thing, though,
is that there's this
part of the brain where,
if you measure sort
of the signals,
they seem to be
completely random.
Like, they just seem
to be random noise.
And so it's like-- it's
strange that there's not
this structure.
It's like, what could this
part of the brain be doing?
Why would it need to be
producing random noise?
What they did--
and this is your--
maybe you bird lovers
out there won't like it--
they took one of these birds.
And while it was
learning-- like,
they waited till a bird
learned like the full song.
And then they deactivated,
through some means,
the part of the brain that
produces random noise.
And nothing happened.
The bird-- apparently, the bird
wasn't like entirely the same.
But it still could
sing the songs fine,
everything like that.
Then they took a bird who was
in the process of learning
the song--
had learned some of it
but wasn't perfect yet
and was still getting better--
and they deactivated
that part of the brain.
And it started just
singing the same song.
Like, how it'd been
singing, it kept singing.
It didn't get any better.
And so that's some
sort of proxy evidence
that this random noise was
related towards the ability
to improve, that it's
not storing the signal,
that it's not necessarily
like the descent itself.
But just this random
noise could be
how it's screwing up
its song in an effort
to get better and better.
It screws up a bit, listens, and
maybe it's a little bit better,
and it does that.
So that's sort of a pretty--
I mean, and sometimes
compelling evidence
that, I mean, biology
could at least use this
as some aspect of
its improvement,
that you shut down the random
noise and it stops learning.
I mean, if you get
the variance to 0,
you're not going to
get worse, you're just
not going to do anything.
You're going to keep
singing the same song.
So that's sort of cool, I think.
Right, so just give you
something to chew on.
There's another
interpretation of this.
So here we sort of
talked about this one.
Here I think our idea was
this sort of sampling,
where we have some
nominal policy.
We perturb it, measure how
good we did, how well we did,
measure performance, and update.
So this is pretty
much what we have,
is we have got some policy
that we're working at.
We add this z to it
that changes it a bit.
We run it, and then we update.
There's a different
interpretation--
my performance got too long.
There's a stochastic
policy interpretation.
Now, in this, the way
you think about it
isn't that we have
some nominal policy
and we're adding noise to it.
It's that your policy
itself acts stochastically.
So actions are random.
Doesn't mean that they're
completely random.
I mean, they're random
with some distribution.
But you're not saying
exactly what you do.
And so you can imagine this
is sort of like if you're
playing Liar's Poker--
you know, where you
hold the card above your head.
And then you can see
anyone else's card but not
your own, and then you sort
of bet on these things.
Do you know the game?
Maybe that game doesn't have
enough cultural penetration
to be a good example.
But if you're playing normal
poker, any sort of gambling
games, if every time
you had the same cards,
if you made the exact same
bet, people could eventually
sort of figure that
out, and maybe they
could use it to beat you.
There's plenty of games like
that, where, say, every time I
have a certain card,
I always bet this.
Then if I bet that
way, they're going
to be like, oh,
he has good cards.
I'm going to fold.
Or, oh, he always bluffs
when he has this card.
So this sort of deterministic
policy doesn't make sense.
The stochastic policy
is exactly what you do.
So your policy is
going to be like, oh,
I've got like pocket kings, 95%
of the time I'm going to raise
whatever, and [INAUDIBLE]
time I'm going to check--
those kind of things, where
you're sort of-- there's
some noise in what you do.
Now, you can question
whether or not
that makes sense as whether
optimal policies would
be stochastic in the kind
of problems we look at.
But the important thing
is just to realize
that your policy, don't think of
it as it's doing these things.
It is these sort of
distributions of what you do.
All right?
So the parameterization,
then, controls distribution.
Ooh.
My fifth grade teacher
would not have liked that.
But.
So what you do, then, you
can imagine you control,
perhaps, the mean
of a distribution.
So where over here we had this--
you can think of it as really
sort of exactly the same, where
my other interpretation
said, OK, my policy is alpha,
and then I add
random noise z to it.
While here, my policy is
parameterized by alpha,
and my action is the same thing.
It's just that it's not,
this is what I'm doing
and I'm sampling something else.
It's that, this is
actually my policy.
If I ran the same policy, I
would just do all these things
with these probabilities.
So it's your actions
are stochastic.
Now, that's sort of something
that isn't always completely--
well, when I first saw it,
it wasn't really easy for me
to get my head around
all what that meant.
But yeah.
So this is-- we're
going to look at this.
Yeah, I won't go
into more detail.
But tomorrow we'll
look at this sort
of different interpretation
of how to do this.
And you can get
the same learning.
we'll actually show that
the update's the same,
the behavior's very similar.
But the properties are
a little bit different.
And the big thing
is that you don't
have to do this linearization.
Here we did this sort
of linear expansion
and we say, OK, so
this is true locally.
When you look at
it in this context,
you can show that
you'll always follow
the gradient of the expected
value of the policy.
All right?
And so that's a big
difference, right?
Here we're saying, OK, we're
looking at the local gradient,
we're going to follow
the local gradient here.
But let's say that you
have a very broad policy
or a very sort of
violent value function.
Let's look at this 1D one again,
where my value function has
something like this--
extremely violent.
Well, when I put this
random stochastic policy,
that smooths it out.
And so even though--
it's because I
have a stochastic policy.
Running my policy, the cost
is a random variable now,
depending on what
my actions are.
Even if my dynamics
are deterministic,
because my policy is stochastic,
my cost is stochastic,
I'm going to get some--
if you look at this,
there's some expected cost
for running this policy on this.
And you do this,
you're going to sort
of-- you can imagine
sort of smoothing out
some of this, right?
Sort of averaging
over all of these.
And what you follow
when you do this--
and the update is
really identical.
Like, it's actually just
the exact same update.
Possibly, there's a coefficient
up front that you could put in
or not.
But the structure is the same.
And the thing is
that it'll follow
the expected value
of the performance
of the stochastic policy.
So it's sort of a
different way of thinking.
I think that this way is sort of
the easier way to sort of first
think about it.
But tomorrow will be more
probability kind of things.
And we'll talk about
the stochastic policy
interpretation and some of
the ramifications of that.
Yeah.
And maybe some other
interesting side notes.
So yeah.